France and its neighboring allies
are shaken by 1 new devastating.
As noted by the President
French Emmanuel Macron,
1 serious moment declared by the Head of State
announces the end of an era for France
marked by the closing of the single currency.
The presidents of the euro zone
make official the disappearance of the Euro,
1 synchronized announcement after the stock market closes
French,
increasing the pressure on Emmanuel Macron.
The impact will be colossal,
but the president calls for
confidence in the face of this uncertainty.
The crucial question arises,
to which I am about to respond,
What is this sudden disappearance?
What to do with the old euros in our possession?
How will the transition to the new currency proceed?
It is essential to
understand that parity is simple,
€1 at exactly the same value as the new currency.
The operators
export-oriented economic activities must be
particularly vigilant in the coming days.
On the other hand,
for those who import,
the results are mostly negative.
Simultaneously,
euro zone leaders
address their citizens,
each country going back to its national currency.
What is your opinion about this unprecedented situation?